إذا كانت روسيا في صاروخ بعيد المدى
مثل الشيطان - اختبرت للتو أو
استهدفت كوريا الشمالية فجأة المقر
الرئيسي للترسانة النووية الأمريكية ،
فلن يكون أمام كبار القادة سوى دقائق
للوصول إلى أمان ضابط كبير في
القيادة الإستراتيجية الأمريكية مع سلطة
إطلاق مضاد  - الهجوم إذا أمر
يجب أن يكون قادرًا على الهروب من إصابة مباشرة
على القاعدة والبقاء على قيد الحياة لإبلاغ
الرئيس أنه سيناريو كابوس
يمارسه بانتظام القائد الأعلى
ذو الأربع نجوم الجنرال جون
الذي زاد من أن الساعة تخبرني أنه يمكنك
دائمًا العثور عليها  سيقوم رئيس الولايات المتحدة
حتى الشاشة على اليسار
بإدراج موقع الرئيس
ونائب الرئيس ووزير الدفاع
والمدعي العام للدولة ،
كل شخص نحتاجه ، ثم
هناك ساعة العد التنازلي وقت الهروب الآمن
مقدار الوقت للوصول إلى
طائرة الهروب عبر نفق سري على متن
مركز القيادة المحمولة جوا e6b ، يُظهر
العميد جريجوري بوين
لنا من حولك ، إذا وصل الأمر
إلينا  تحدثت إلى الرئيس ترامب من هذه
الطائرة ، نعم إذا كان هذا هو أسوأ يوم في
تاريخ أمريكا وكان هذا هو الشيء الوحيد
المتبقي نعم من هذه اللوحة ،
يمكن إطلاق الصواريخ الباليستية العابرة للقارات من
الصوامع الموجودة تحت الأرض ، والمفاتيح تذهب هنا
وكل شيء في الطريق النووي.
العالم هو أن يتحكم الشخص في وجود
شخصين يجب عليهما إدارة المفاتيح
والآخر يجلس خلفك
وبعد ذلك لدي مفتاح هنا
لتمكين النظام فعليًا ومن هنا
باستخدام هوائي سري يطير من
الجزء الخلفي من الطائرة
يمكن للغواصات المختبئة في أعماق المحيط
أن تحصل أيضًا على أوامر مباشرة
لإطلاق صواريخها ، ويمكننا التواصل
مع غواصاتنا على مدار الساعة طوال أيام الأسبوع بغض النظر عن مكان
وجودهم في العالم مع
الترسانات النووية لكوريا الشمالية وروسيا الآن مصدر
قلق كبير هذا هو المركز  من
الجهود العسكرية للبقاء خارج الحرب